this is tamar hussein reading for
reviewer alessandro barbosa aliens fire
team elite trades the slow tension of
escaping one extraterrestrial predator
for the chaos of trying to survive waves
of hundreds at a time while not without
its issues it has a surprisingly deep
progression system consistently
entertaining firefights and an
engrossing presentation that keeps the
action gripping throughout
whoa careful seals loose
akin to squad-based shooters such as
left 4 dead aliens fire team elite plays
out over a series of acts that are part
of larger chapters with each one
featuring new enemies and set pieces for
your team of three colonial marines to
tackle headfirst the story leans heavily
into iconography from the recent alien
films most notably pulling influences
from prometheus and in some cases
directly referencing events from the
divisive project this is a nice touch to
make each chapter feel like it has a
significant place within the universe
the third person action is the
foundation on which everything is built
though and it's a strong one at that
alien's fire team elite pulls generously
from the pool of weapons available to
colonial marines with a recognizable
pulse rifle just being the tip of the
iceberg in terms of enjoyable weaponry
you'll be able to wield
there are notable inclusions in every
tier of weapon type with powerful
flamethrowers and enemy seeking smart
guns making heavy weapons as desirable
as a birth shot hand cannon or sound off
shotgun in the sidearm category each
weapon can be customized with three
attachments too letting you enhance
their effectiveness against stronger
enemies while also imbuing them with
unique abilities attachments also
contribute to your overall combat rating
a numerical value used to determine your
offensive ability like those used in
games like destiny incentivizing you to
routinely consult the merchant in the
game's hub world and seek out hidden
caches in each act to unlock more
vitamin elite features five classes for
you to choose from four initially with
one final one unlocking once you finish
the game and each has active and passive
abilities as well as loadout options the
standard gunner class for example has
access to one rifle slot and one cqc
slot letting you take in a pulse rifle
and a shotgun into battle the tactician
on the other hand can only use a smaller
sidearm and cqc weapons but has access
to a deployable turret and shock grenade
that is extremely effective at crowd
control
harder difficulties press you to
consider what abilities your current
squad of three offer and how to better
prepare for the challenges encountered
in each individual level having three
heavy demolishers sounds like a winning
strategy but this can leave you
vulnerable during extended defense
sequences which are plentiful you
customize each class further using a
perk system with numerous modifiers and
banners unlocked as you level up its
respective class this system seems to
take inspiration from resident evil 4
you have a grid with a limited number of
spaces where you can place new modifiers
and perks each of which have distinct
shapes and sizes some modifiers need to
be placed on particular sides of the
grid in order to affect one of your
active abilities leading to further
complexity when attempting to maximize
the space you have effectively it's a
little strange at first compounded by
the absence of a tutorial that breaks
down some of the system's nuances but
once you've unlocked a reasonable amount
of space it is a crucial component of
your overall progression unlocking
abilities and combinations that will be
vital to success on higher difficulties
[Music]
the ways in which your chosen weapons
selected classes and equipped
attachments effect gameplay is directly
influenced by which enemies you're
matched up with an alien's fire team
elite has a deep pool of aliens and
androids that it pulls from some are
immediately familiar in terms of
archetypes they populate the prowler
hides on ceilings and pins you down
while another explodes into a puddle of
acid blood when killed but there are
numerous others that all introduce new
combat wrinkles to consider the drone
emerges from vents and crawl spaces to
do some quick damage before disappearing
again making it a consistent threat
until you manage to kill it heavily
armored synthetics will force you to
engage with cover mechanics in a way
that fast running xenomorphs don't
challenging you to break from your
established muscle memory aliens
fireteam elite uses enemy sizes and
skill sets to constantly keep you
adapting to their respective threats
also available for purchase are
consumables that can be used once during
any run which includes sentries with
limited ammunition an assortment of
elemental mines and useful recon drones
that buff damage to enemies they mark
perhaps one of the most useful
consumables are challenge cards which
can be activated before a run to change
how it plays out these can make things
easier like giving you double the health
or more ammunition but the most
interesting ones are those that change
the rule set and increase the
probability of failure in return for
drastic credits and experience boost
some memorable ones include a card that
constantly introduces a drone into the
mix meaning the team is always hunted by
a strong and deadly foe
another turned all regular enemies into
exploding variants while another reduced
regular damage by a third but tripled
weak point damage
each of these change the way you
approach a particular act and shakes up
the gameplay in fun and tangible ways
making otherwise routine motions through
a level feel fresh again this is
particularly welcome in the face of
objectives in each level boiling down to
the same structure throughout which does
become stale rather quickly each stage
is a linear path from one big ambush
section to the next peppering the route
with some exciting engagements against
pockets of enemies
but the indicators of your progression
through the stage never really changed
once you reach an area with an ammo box
and some spare health you know you're
about to dig in deep and defend your
position for a bit on your toes fire
team
on the flank
with each level usually containing
anywhere between two to three of these
sections throughout this further dilutes
the horde mode that is only unlocked
once you've finished it given that it's
just a distillation of the same
objective you've been doing and
repeating to get there
there are sparse exceptions to this rule
especially the final climactic escape
which dials up the alien horror as far
as it goes in the game but if you aren't
playing around with challenge cards or
plunging into harder difficulties the
level design of each stage doesn't do
enough to keep things exciting while it
may lack in mission design each act does
deliver in terms of outstanding visual
presentation
each takes place in a new area which
slowly evolves over time as you make
your way through it it's steeped in
familiar iconography and eye-catching
details lighting in these areas do a
great job of both highlighting its
attention to authenticity while also
offering numerous pockets of darkness
for threats to hide in making tracking
incoming xenomorphs suitably difficult
and tense weapons also stand out in
terms of how they brighten up each scene
with their deadly ordnance with the
searing flames of the flamethrower
standing out in particular it's all
faithful to alien even when the gameplay
isn't grounding the action within the
franchise even if its pace couldn't be
further from it playing alone sadly does
a disservice to the entire experience
while also diluting many of the
strategic and dynamic elements of
fighting elite with other players you're
constantly making calls and pinging
dangerous enemies while also composing
your team carefully for the challenge
ahead alone you're just playing with two
ai bots who are competent at best when
it comes to aiding you but they don't
have the ability to intelligently
synergize with your chosen classes
abilities when it matters which in turn
makes harder difficulties almost
impossible
aliens fire team elite acknowledges this
when choosing anything above its regular
difficulty recommending player
controlled teammates over the bots which
severely limits replayability if you're
wanting to go at it solo despite what
its reduced price point may suggest
there's a lot here to keep you
entertained for numerous hours
especially once you've managed your
first run through all four acts and
start tackling them again with higher
difficulty settings in the pursuit of
consistently better gear there's so much
satisfaction in customizing and managing
a handful of classes with enough depth
to transform them into the colonial
marine you need at a given time along
with a plethora of great weapons to make
the moment-to-moment action engaging
from the first time you pull the trigger
what aliens fire team elite lacks in
dread it makes up for in pure white
knuckle action making it a great place
to engage with this iconic sci-fi
franchise again
patching up